[Music]
you are watching the press preview the
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the economist
carol malone and the editor of the
career in dundee david clegg they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight carol is going to be joining
you i'm sure some technical difficulties
at the moment but we hope to sort those
out for you so let's see what's on some
of those front pages for you now
the daily express is leading with the
prime minister boris johnson allies that
say they don't want a repeat of the
thatcher betrayal
the metro proclaims plan a okay in
response to the end of plan b covid
restrictions today
the telegraph understands that the
treasury intends to close a loophole
which allowed people to claim a tax
credit of 125 pounds if they worked from
home even for a single day
the eye hears the prime minister's plan
to tackle the cost of living crisis is
being delayed by what it calls the
turmoil in downing street
treasury alarmed says the guardian as
the pm refuses to confirm the national
insurance rise in an attempt to save his
job
the mirror writes andrew's ultimate
gamble leaving the palace in fear over a
trial
according to the financial times the uk
and the eu are threatening to impose
sanctions on new russian oil projects if
moscow decides to invade ukraine
david's paper the courier reports that
the nhs trust for tayside is facing the
prospect of not having any breast cancer
specialists on its staff at all
and the star is uh nessie lost
a disorientated beast seen in wimbledon
could it be the loch ness monster
stranger things have happened
this week
so they say
with me now uh david clegg and hopefully
carol malone uh soon too hi david uh
you're all on your lonesome for the
moment we'll try and sort that out let's
start with the metro uh their front page
plan a
okay this is a shift in how we will all
live our lives from uh
now onwards
yes well in england anyway and
unfortunately where i am in scotland at
the minute we haven't quite got as loose
restrictions as as the english have been
enjoying today so i'm looking on quite
enviously at the uh the pictures on the
metro today of phil tube stations and
people going back to work that hasn't
quite happened here yet although uh
working from home guidance is changing
from next week so we are beginning to
move back into that but it is positive
signs i think and there does seem to be
a general sense of optimism still that
um
we are returning to some kind of
normality or or certainly that uh life
is uh easing up a little bit with what
we can do so i think there has been a
lot of positivity around and that's been
reflected on the front of the metro
tomorrow although some things are going
to be kept for instance on uh public
transport uh london on the ground they
will still require people who travel to
to wear mars and some supermarkets have
voluntarily stepped up and said that
they will still ask their customers to
wear mars so it's not quite back to
normal
no i think the face mask the face mask
issue is quite interesting because you
have um this
it's going to be voluntary now in uh
areas in england but some supermarkets
asking customers to wear it train
companies asking customers to wear it it
doesn't seem like a massive opposition
to me and i think it will be quite
interesting to see what happens with
that now that people are being asked to
show their civic spirit by wearing a
face mask rather than
for legal reasons so they're they're
that is not the case in scotland i
should say the the the face mask
regulations are going to
remain stricter here than they are in
england i think probably for the
foreseeable i think that is something
where we see a definitive uh difference
between the scottish government's ethos
and the uk government's e-force on that
so i think we will still see uh slightly
more requirements for face mask wearing
in scotland than in england
for the foreseeable future i mean
potentially it does cause problems for
um travelers and people in in
supermarkets because
you can't actually
enforce the mask wearing so you know if
somebody isn't wearing a mask you can't
say you're supposed to put your mask on
so it does
provide a bit of conflict doesn't it
i i would be
i would be very reluctant or
somewhat worried about asking
supermarket workers to become the
enforcers of face masks especially in an
environment where the government is
saying that it isn't compulsory anymore
so i i'll be interesting to see why the
supermarkets that are continuing to ask
customers in england to wear face masks
approach the issue of them of them not
doing that given given the legal
uh situation i i imagine it will be a
rather soft enforcement but it could
certainly lead to some difficulties uh
if there was a if there was a problem
there or a pension with a customer who
was refusing to wear a face mask against
the request of the store yes yes it
could do we shall have to see how that
pans out let's move on to the the
guardian and this is a story about the
prime minister refusing to rule out um
a rising national insurance increase we
know that uh rishi sunak is is for this
but there are very many members of the
cabinet uh that don't believe
rise is warranted right now uh the prime
minister has not said either way what's
going to happen
i think there's this is a really
interesting story and i think it tells
us something uh about the wider
situation in the government this this
tonight's been in my diary for a while
to come and do the papers here and at
one point earlier in the week i thought
you know we could be talking about sue
grey's report that that could have been
published today and we we could have had
quite a dramatic situation about the
prime minister's future that's not where
we are
this evening what we're at we're at that
situation where his future is still very
much in the mix it's we're on
tenterhooks about what exactly is going
to happen what that report is going to
say and what it will mean and i think
what we're seeing a theme through some
of the papers tomorrow including the
meal is that what what is boris
johnson's vulnerability what is boris
johnson's fragility of his position what
is that going to mean for policy if he
stays on so the meal is reporting oh
sorry that the the
tax rise could
not go ahead and therefore
because he's trying to appease uh tory
right-wing mps who clearly are against
this policy and are hoping that
uh they can maneuver him to change now
he's not said anything about this it
hasn't uh it is very much uh
still in the balance i think but it's
certainly there's a move on against it
and it'll be interesting to see what
happens in the in the days ahead yes and
then that tax rises to to pay for an
injection uh into the national health
service that's been widely reported and
according to the article healthcare
bosses have urged johnson to ensure the
resources get to the nhs without this
extra funding the public will face
longer waits for treatment and hundreds
of thousands of vulnerable people won't
get the care and support they need uh
from social care so that there is a quid
pro quo isn't there um and boris johnson
seems to be um juggling
well very much so and also this is a
flagship policy that was in and you know
it was announced with massive fanfare
and and the the theme of it is that the
health service needs this money that
social care has been struggling so badly
before the pandemic even and now we've
got the extra pressures on there so the
question is if there is concern for
political reasons about the highest they
were proposing to raise this cash to to
to
capitulate on that because of nonsense
and and triviality in downing street and
concerns about the character of the
prime minister if that is beginning to
impact on you know such an important
issue the central how you fund proper
health care for for the for your
populace it i think it gets to the heart
of the problem that we have with the the
government at the minute that uh
personal the personal character of the
prime minister uh what's been going on
behind the scenes in downing streets uh
is
speaks to the the central character of
course of the government but also can
really uh dereal their policy platform
uh if the if the prime minister is no
longer able to rely on his backbenchers
and as having to uh
bribe them almost with changes of
policies that are central and extremely
important for uh the contingent function
of the government platform
david i've got good news for you i can
save your voice for a couple of seconds
uh because carol joins us now welcome
carol
i'm so sorry
technological problems sorry you're here
now
who's just gonna say something nice
there don't
come on
you're allowed one nice thing to say
i've never been so happy to see you
that's good i'm here hello
so carol you're here now um we were just
talking about the national insurance um
hike the proposed rise and the fact that
the prime minister seems to be uh
delaying a decision on this despite um
members of his cabinet not agreeing with
with the the rise in national insurance
but the guardian's suggesting that it's
because he doesn't want to be unpopular
and it's a very difficult time for him
yeah i mean
i think if boris wants to save
himself
this government and the tory parties he
has to to to stop this tax act you know
we you know i i get the fact that sunak
wants to do this i get why because the
pandemic has to be paid for um and we
and the social care crisis has to be
dealt with of course but you know the
economic landscape of this country has
changed enormously in the past year year
and a half and we're you know we're in a
cost of living crisis you know the the
cost of domestic fuel for us is going to
go up by 50 percent come april mortgages
are going up
people are soon gonna be facing hellish
choices about whether they can eat or
heat their homes and and what they do
not need at this time is this tax you
know this is absolutely the wrong moment
for this tax and boris will lose
everyone if he presses on with this you
know if we if we've got enough money to
send weapons to ukraine if we've got
enough money to awards we have enough
money to delay this hike people have got
to get a breath and and people are
literally going to be going into poverty
coming for when this cap has taken off
carol well done you've talked us right
up until the break and made up for your
absence at the start
karen david stay right there where you
are we're going to take a break coming
up more including this from the front
page of the telegraph gp's told to see
more patients face to face do stay with
us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me cara malone and
david clegg there they are i thought you
were going to desert me forever for a
while there um right let's um let's kick
off with the um the metro because we
didn't get a chance to talk about
rhubarb and it's not in the context of a
crumble what are we talking about david
uh so this is boris johnston's very
colorful turn of phrase uh and his
denial that he had personally approved
uh the use of government resources or
indeed the help the government support
in
taking the the dogs from kabul and
afghanistan last year it's an issue that
attracted a lot of attention at the time
and there was a a very high profile and
quite skillfully executed campaign by
the charity involved to to get these
dogs to safety but it's not it's now it
became uh
somewhat the controversy is about well
their pets have been prioritized over
people in this issue and the government
have denied this there was there's
there's you know
really conflicting accounts now that uh
weller boris johnson had got this flight
approved and cleared or whether this had
been uh done by officials or wet weather
met his attention and it's still there's
still something not quite right about it
the accounts just can't really be made
to square
boris johnson has said it is total
rhubarb i guess
and we'll have to leave it to the
uh audience to decide whether boris
johnson signed something his total
rhubarb is believable or not or whether
we have credibility to his uh colorful
turns of phrases yeah never actually
heard that phrase before but but he is
insisting that uh
human beings were prioritized
over animals
carol
so yeah we're cutting out yeah um well
he's saying that but foreign office
officials were saying we're referencing
have referenced emails quotes
um the pm's and nozod now's that i can't
pronounce it the charity decision
they have been referenced as his emails
and his decision to do this now you know
we know at the time we saw those scenes
at kabul airport we saw
thousands of people claiming to get on
planes we know that some of the afghan
interpreters were there we know that
those people didn't get on planes but
what we do know is that a plane full of
dogs and cats did get off the ground and
if you remember at the time there was a
massive fuss with penn farving causing a
fuss over there saying that if his plane
wasn't allowed to go he would make a
phone call
to someone an authority and he was
furious and screaming um and and also
we think there may be
um carrie's hand in it um
there is talk tonight of carrie being
involved with
zach goldsmith in this
um so you know there's a bit of a bit of
a bit of a red herring and bringing
carrie into it it's you know it's it's
not really part of the odds
if we just why do you say
we just got quickly time to go to
um we don't we've run out of time carol
i'm sorry we've run out of time carol
and david thank you both we'll see you
in the next hour